key to being a good dad sometimes things
work out just the way you want
sometimes they don't
gotta hang in there
ninety percent of being a dad
just showing up
emergency assistance
we lost our baby in the car and people
are judging us
do not break the window you get glass on
her please tell your wife to relax
everything is going to be okay that's a
man really
really Daddy's
Daddy's come check out check the door
check the door check the door it's not
oh
okay that is amazing
how did they do that I don't know it's
just we got it thank you come from space
think fast oh wow buddy I'm sorry I told
you I gotta change the light bulbs and
then hope your mom with those signatures
I've always said that if my son thinks
of me as one of his Idiot Friends that
I've succeeded as a dad if he wants to
go the wrong way on the escalator I'm on
board if he wants to go into a
restaurant and pretend we're Australian
think g'day mate toss a few shrimp on
the baby from me and my Joey yeah right
Nicole Kidman Men At Work
here we go take 12. hey buddy I'm home
hey Dad think fast oh
ah now my arm's starting to hurt a
little really because my face feels
great hello
hey Javier
Manny's waiting for you outside
what
why not
hold that thought
his son's sitting on a curb waiting to
go to Disneyland and Superman can't drag
himself away from a craps table
and I'm the jerk
say listen
I uh
sorry but I got some bad news what your
dad couldn't make it
why not
the plane was full and this old lady
needed to get home
so he gave up his seat you're making
that up aren't you no
he just didn't want to come are you
kidding me he was very upset he was
dying to see you
[Music]
in fact look what he said
a limo yeah
they wanted me and your mom to take you
to Disneyland I told you he was an
awesome dad yeah he's a prince
I cuddled her more than any other loving
parent
it's possible
and for Lily's sake I should probably
work on that
give me your credit card bill
also uh this restaurant is pretty far
away so we might be out well sweetheart
you are only young once well it might
even make sense to just stay in a hotel
okay put it on the plastic great
okay see you tomorrow bye-bye
it's my ex-wife not the good one what do
you want
nice game of chicken Claire she's gone
she's coming back I am almost positive
almost why do I listen to you why you
were wrong about the iPod being a
failure you were wrong about tomato
being a vegetable I only want to talk
about your favorite planet Pluto and
unless she was lying to the good ladies
of the view it's to me not Demi
you're going to let me go with him isn't
that what you wanted honey what's the
matter with you you've been acting so
weird ever since I left college for the
record you didn't leave College you were
asked to leave oh which you guys never
let me forget especially dad honey your
father oh you don't have to tell me what
he thinks okay I'm a huge disappointment
to him I see it on his face every day he
asks if he doesn't even want me around
give me the ticket for the car I'm going
after her this little chicken game may
work for your dad but it doesn't work
for me that's my little girl I need her
to know that no guy on earth is good
enough for her let alone some slimy
middle-aged Jean salesman
what's this just enjoy it
if your teacher tells me you don't want
to dance is that true
but you were so good back at the house
when you were practicing I want to go
home to my house ah to your house huh
are you sad your dads aren't here
yeah
well I know they're sad to miss this but
they're getting you that baby brother
that's good right
you know honey
your dads are going to love you just as
much when you get this brother trust me
I first had your Aunt Claire and then
your dad came along and I love them just
the same
no matter what he tells you
believe me
close enough
so what do you say you're gonna go out
there and dance for everybody
no
honey there must be something I can do
to get you out there
no honey that's not going to happen how
about I give you 50 bucks
[Music]
now Lily and I are getting married
uh what's happening when she propose I
thought it was a little weird but then I
read it's a phase that some girls go
through so oh no well I just think it's
the cutest thing ever here Dad I made
you this ring oh cute cute cute cute
cute cute cute cute cute
do you have a ring for me well Lily it
wouldn't be a wedding without a ring yay
loving this daddy move okay I guess I'll
just go sit on the groom side oh come on
cam it's fun oh it's fun it's it's super
fun he finally got married hooray
are you okay sweetie what do you think
wait a minute you won congratulations
please don't be happy for me I can't
take it I'm such a jerk to you no honey
I get it
I uh I know I can be embarrassing I
I just get nervous around smart people
sometimes even you
the first time I ever said quite quite
was when you were six years old and you
just told me about how plants make
carbon dioxide this may surprise you but
sometimes I wish I was more like you
the way you're always able to enjoy life
believe it or not I felt the same way
about my dad I'm a I'm a pessimist
compared to him and his dad actually
suffered from a smile induced hernia
we can
four best years of
only I forgot to make them the four best
years of my life
well College isn't over
and I just may be able to help you make
up for a little lost time hot wing
trivia is about to start I have you guys
registered as at the dumpies
you know I was coming let's not forget
where you learned about that tracking
app
and there's one tiny change we're
actually the Mac donkeys
only my dad would think that a trivia
game the triangle shirts waste fire
where you balance hats on your head
drink beer as a reward Kareem
Abdul-Jabbar
and eat hot wings as a punishment
Millard Fillmore
needed that one last Twist of a Scottish
accent doopy
[Music]
Sneezy and grumpy
no no no no no take those things off
please we need to talk about whatever's
going on with you right now I'm fine no
you're not fine we're Sullen and aloof
and and you embarrassed us in front of
Kimmy love and stuff I can't say it
again I can't okay we gave you every
tween girls dream day and and you could
barely crack a smile it's not my dream
day it's yours I'm not the same kind of
tween girl you guys are but we love all
the same things I've changed I don't
like Beyonce oh take that back or
Brittany
I only fake it because you guys like
that stuff I'm Different well honey is
it is that why you've been feeling so
down because you you feel different than
us I don't know I guess I feel different
than a lot of people well
sweetie that is one thing your dad and I
can relate to I guess that's the great
thing about having two gay dads we we
know what it feels like to be an
outsider okay but here's what happens
you start finding people who don't quite
fit in and you start not fitting in
together we never want you to feel like
you have to be someone else for us ever
what is this music you're always
listening to come on let us in yeah okay
I like this put it on huh here we go
five yeah yeah yeah I like it
she's gonna kill us someday how often do
your fathers get married
so far one
two why am I still seeing you
[Music]
look at that we're about to start
actually I thought you and I would take
a little walk
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]